(piano music)
- [Michael] A castell is a
structure formed of human people.
It's a human tower.
Castells are a Catalan
tradition of over 200 years.
Today, there are over 80
different colles or teams
spread throughout Catalunya.
Every two years we have a competition.
The twelve best teams will
perform at the Concurs
in Tarragona.
I'm proud to be a member of
the Castellers de Vilafranca.
The Castellers de Vilafranca
have won the Concurs
for seven consecutive times.
We hope to make it eight
consecutive victories.
These are very big
structures, very big castles
and they require three or
four hundred people at a time
to make these kind of
constructions and they can reach
heights of 15 meters.
The most important thing when
we try to make the castles
is obviously the safety
of the people involved.
We have very small children
of the age of four or five
who will climb to the
very top of the castle.
Everybody is working to make
sure that this is the safest
possible activity for them.
This is very important
because occasionally castles
will collapse and it looks
spectacular but it can be
very dangerous.
It's quite common for people
to break a leg, an arm,
shoulder injuries.
As the castle progresses,
the pressure builds.
Everybody is trying to find
the little bit of oxygen
in the bottom of the castle.
There have been times when
people have fainted or collapsed,
but you still have to keep
going because you have
the collective responsibility
that you don't want to let
the team down.
When you hear the final music
that you know the castle
is completed, you can relax
a little bit but you still
have to concentrate because
this is the most dangerous part
of the castle because if you
relax too much, the structure
can collapse very, very quickly.
Why am I a Casteller de Vilafranca?
This is a very complex question
and I don't really have
an answer.
You can't explain it, it's
impossible to explain.
You have to feel it.
If you feel it, you understand it.